[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers
guten Abend in allen wir haben in
Deutschland nicht das beste Wetter die
unbeschwerteste Lebensfreude oder das
Talent leichtfüßig zu tanzen aber uns
jahrzehntelang damit getröstet dass
dafür etwas anderes gilt Deutschland
funktioniert
auch diese Gewissheit bröckelt marode
Brücken unzuverlässiger Schienenverkehr
absurde Bürokratie abgehängt bei der
Digitalisierung und jetzt rufen die
Alarm die wir sonst alarmieren weil es
um Leib und Leben geht die Helfer
brauchen Hilfe die Notfallrettung in
Deutschland stehe vor dem Kollaps warnt
ein Bündnis von Fachverbänden und
Gewerkschaften
aus Berlin wo die Feuerwehr in ihrer
Verzweiflung Löschtrupps schickt weil
Sanitäter und Krankenwagen fehlen
berichten Markus groß und Stefan
Zustand bei unbekannten psychiatrischen
Notfall ein Mensch ist in Not Alltag auf
dem Rettungswagen noch auf der Rückfahrt
vom letzten Einsatz Erreichtes Team
schon der nächste Ruf so ist es oft RTW
12041 quält sich hier durch Berlin aber
es sieht deutschlandweit ähnlich aus
Retter beklagen dass es immer mehr
Einsatzfahrten gibt oft für
Kleinigkeiten es zu wenig
Rettungspersonal gibt und deshalb oft
Wagen auf der Straße fehlen was die
Arbeit für die anderen natürlich
vermehrt diese Gemengelage kann
gefährlich werden
das läuft in eine Katastrophe so würde
ich es einfach mal ganz schlicht und
einfach bezeichnen wir werden in der
Zukunft wenn wir jetzt nicht ändern
nicht mehr genug Rettungswagen auf der
Straße haben um jeden einen anzubieten
und dann werden Sie entweder warten oder
wir werden Zustände haben wo sie alleine
in ein Krankenhaus gefahren müssen um
eine Versorgung zu bekommen erst am
Wochenende hat sich in Berlin gezeigt
was das heißt ein BVG-Bus erfasst zwei
Jugendliche eine 15-jährige stirbt ein
Notarzt ist nach Feuerwehrangaben in 9
Minuten zur Stelle ein Rettungswagen
braucht 20 vorher war keiner verfügbar
auf die Hilfe hätte es sich nicht
ausgewirkt aber Berlins feuerwehrgerät
fast täglich in den Ausnahmezustand
wir haben zu wenig Rettungswagen es
gelingt uns auch aufgrund der Personal
angespannten personalsituationen die
Rettungswagen die wir eigentlich
benötigen nicht auf die Straße zu
bringen wir müssen rein rechnerisch 140
Rettungswagen täglich auf die Straße
bringen und das schaffen wir nicht immer
öfter werden deshalb sogar
Löschfahrzeuge zu Erste Hilfe einsetzen
geschickt überbrücken bis der
Rettungswagen kommt und improvisieren in
der Not der Rettungsdienst in
Deutschland ist überlastet Verzögerungen
gibt es täglich nicht einmal daran dass
wir lange brauchen um einen Krankenhaus
mit einem freien Bett zu finden an der
Einsatzstelle dass wir aber auch an den
Krankenhäusern durch die
Belastungssituation in den
Krankenhäusern lange Wartezeiten haben
bis das Rettungsfachpersonal aber auch
die Notärzte den Patienten an die
Krankenhäuser weitergeben können und wer
noch an der Notaufnahme ansteht fehlt
auf der Straße die Retter brauchen
selbst Hilfe haben heute ihr Bündnis pro
Rettungsdienst vorgestellt wollen
endlich als wichtiger Bestandteil des
Gesundheitswesens anerkannt werden
einzeln haben wir natürlich immer viel
Gespräche Politikern die verheilen aber
meistens und wir hoffen uns von dem
Zusammenschluss der wichtigsten
Beteiligten im Rettungsdienst dass wir
gemeinsam an einen Tisch kommen und uns
überlegen wie wir diese Probleme lösen
können als die Berliner Retter bei der
psychischen Notlage vom Anfang der
Geschichte eintreffen steht der Rauchen
vor seiner Haustür und will in die
Klinik gefahren werden sie versuchen
sich nicht zu ärgern
zu dem Thema nachher im heute journal
Update Fragen von Nazan gökdemir an
einen Vertreter des neu gegründeten
Bündnisses pro Rettungsdienst
Korruption ist Gift für die Demokratie
weil es deren Grundlage untergräbt unser
aller Vertrauen in die Arbeit der
Volksvertreter frei von äußeren
Einflüssen in Gestalt etwa von Taschen
voller Geld in kleinen Scheinen sind
Säcke voller Geld die die einzigen
gewählten Volksvertreter erschüttern die
die Europäische Union hat das
Europaparlament hätte gern mehr macht es
lebt von Glaubwürdigkeit und Integrität
umso verheerender könnte der
schmiergeld-skandal wären und werden um
die bisherige griechische
Vizepräsidentin und fünf andere
Beschuldigte die Staatsanwaltschaft hat
heute das Parlament durchsuchen lassen
und mit seinem ganz eigenen Gespür für
PR hat sich Ungarns premier Viktor Orban
gemeldet dieses Europaparlament soll
ernsthaft besorgt sein über Korruptionen
Ungarn fragt er mit voller Schadenfreude
Isabel Schäfers berichtet
Heime Sitzung hier soll heute niemand
rein der hier nicht reingehört deshalb
gibt es strenge Einlasskontrollen bei
der Krisensitzung der
sozialdemokratischen Fraktion im
Europaparlament die Fraktion der auch
Eva kaii angehörte die nun unter
Korruptionsverdacht steht ernste Minen
bei den Abgeordneten ich bin wütend und
enttäuscht dass jemand aus unserer
Fraktion kriminelle Energie aufwendet
das ist für mich auch immer noch ein
unfassbarer Schock und es ist ganz klar
etwas das zeigt eine kriminelle Energie
die kein politisches Hause hat im Plenum
bleibt Kylies Platz heute leer dennoch
ist sie Thema Nummer eins der
korruptionskandal beschäftigt nicht nur
die europäischen Sozialdemokraten
sondern das ganze Parlament die
Parlamentspräsidentin lässt keinen
Zweifel es ist ernst
das Europäische Parlament wird
angegriffen die europäische Demokratie
wird angegriffen und unser Weg offener
freier demokratischer Gesellschaften
wird angegriffen
Demokratie
es sollen Konsequenzen gezogen werden
und zwar schnell
Truhe wir müssen eine Lösung finden
dieser Skandal muss dazu führen dass
Lobbygruppen externe Behörden und
Drittstaaten nicht mehr ins Europäische
Parlament kommen können als wäre es ein
Supermarkt um unsere Stimmen zu kaufen
außerdem sollen die angedachten Visa
Erleichterungen für Katara erst einmal
nicht kommen
es ist so dass ich nicht davon ausgehe
das total in den nächsten Jahren
irgendeine Chance haben sollte eine
dieser Liberalisierung zu bekommen auch
die EU
-come Post ich schlage vor eine
unabhängige ethikstelle einzurichten
zuständig für alle EU-Institutionen das
Europaparlament unter Druck sonst so auf
die Institution die klare Kante fordert
gegen Korruption wie im Fall Ungarn und
so war es wohl vorhersehbar dass es
Orban sichtlich Schadenfreude bereitete
sich auf Twitter über das
Europaparlament lustig zu machen
Orban versucht die Situation auszunutzen
aber ich denke an die Menschen in Ungarn
die überhaupt niemanden haben der sie
vor Korruption schützt
während die Abgeordneten in Straßburg
versuchen den Skandal aufzuarbeiten
durchsucht die Polizei in Brüssel weiter
Büros beschlagnahmt Computer
Umfang ist erheblich es geht um
Korruption Geldwäsche kriminelle
Organisation auf europäischer Ebene es
geht also weiter noch es nicht klar was
alles ans Licht kommen wird eine ernste
Lage für ein Parlament was sich sonst
eher in der Rolle sieht das
vielverhalten anderer anzumahnen
Katharina barley ist die Vizepräsidentin
des Europaparlaments und jetzt bei uns
schönen guten Abend
guten Abend das Europäische Parlament
wird angegriffen die europäische
Demokratie wird angegriffen sagt die
Parlamentspräsidentin heute wer ist denn
der Angreifer die eigene Vizepräsidentin
oder ein Golfstaat
offensichtlich ein arabischer Staat der
versucht Stimmen zu kaufen und leider
gibt es auch in diesem Parlament
anscheinend Menschen die schwach sind
schlechte Menschen sind wie auch immer
man das Definieren mag jedenfalls die
sich dafür hergeben das ist wirklich
erschütternd wir werden dieses Parlament
gründlich durchschütteln sagt die
Präsidentin heute auch das klingt jetzt
als ob da noch viel mehr kommt
nun die Untersuchung laufen das sind
staatsanwaltlicher Ermittlungen und alle
hier kooperieren mit den Behörden da
gibt es überhaupt keine Frage ich weiß
nicht wie sie das gemeint hat es kann
auch sein dass sie das gemeint hat im
Sinne von wir müssen gucken was wir noch
besser machen können hier auch als
Parlament um sowas zu verhindern okay
wir müssen das Parlament durchschütteln
da stellt sich vielleicht auch eine ganz
andere Frage warum braucht das
Europaparlament eigentlich 14
vizepräsidentinnen und Präsidenten
tja da fragen Sie jetzt die absolut
falsch ich wollte das war schon so als
ich hierher kam aber tatsächlich so dass
genau genau also wir sind hier
natürlich Vertretungen für die
Präsidentin das heißt Sitzungsdienst
muss gemacht werden wir haben hier
wesentlich mehr Sitzungen als als zum
Beispiel der Bundestag das muss unter
allen aufgeteilt werden da kann ja nicht
einer von morgens bis abends da hocken
wir haben eigene Zuständigkeitsbereiche
also wir haben schon alle gut zu tun in
Brüssel sind heute Abgeordneten Büros
durchsucht worden von der Polizei die
Abgeordneten selbst sitzen im Moment
gerade in Straßburg wo wir auch mit
Ihnen reden der Wahnsinn dieses
Parlaments Wanderzirkus das wird jetzt
endgültig zum Problem oder
also wenn es irgendwie beruhigt auch in
Straßburg sind heute Büros durchsucht
worden nein im Ernst also dieser
Wanderzirkus der macht niemandem von uns
Spaß das dürfen sie sich nicht so
vorstellen das ist auch für uns mit Zeit
kosten Nerven verbunden
es steht aber leider in den europäischen
Verträgen das heißt das lässt sich nur
einstimmig ändern und da hat Frankreich
bisher immer etwas dagegen gehabt vorbei
sie kennen die Hauptbeschuldigte sie
sind Kollegin von ihnen als
Vizepräsidentin bisherige
Vizepräsidentin die Vorwürfe betreffen
aktuell alle samt Mitglieder der
sozialdemokratischen Parteienfamilie
ihrer Parteienfamilie ist die besonders
anfällig warum ist das so
wenn man sich mal die Geschichte
anschaut dann wird man sehen dass die
Sozialdemokratische Partei immer
diejenige ist die am stärksten für
Demokratie und Rechtsstaatlichkeit und
gegen Korruption kämpft aber auch wir
haben Einzelfälle ja wie gesagt auch wir
sind eine Partei aus Menschen und da
finden sie hin und wieder eben auch mal
jemanden der
vom rechten Fahrt abbekommt und das ist
hier der Fall Menschen sind auch in den
anderen Anteilen vorbei warum betrifft
es aktuell die Sozialdemokraten so
massiv
naja wie gesagt das ist jetzt ein ein
Fall wir hatten andere denken Sie an die
maskenaffäre denken Sie an die
aserbaidschan-affäre im Deutschen
Bundestag da war es die Union wir haben
hier einen Ministerpräsidenten der
Tschechischen Republik gehabt also von
den Liberalen der korrupt ist oder war
also das ist nichts was auf einem
Parteienfamilie beschränkt das ist auch
nicht was auf die Politik beschränkt ist
wir haben
in der Politik wie überall in der
Gesellschaft leider gute und schlechte
Menschen was wir tun müssen ist alles
tun es zu verhindern dass es passiert
und wenn es passiert ganz entschieden
aufklären und das tun wir es ist ja
offenbar so dass Staaten zumindest ein
Staat aktuell ganz massiv versucht
Einfluss zu nehmen indem er besticht im
Lobbyregister das da gegen Transparenz
bringen soll da stehen ausdrücklich
keine Drittstaaten drin als Akteure
warum eigentlich nicht
das hat natürlich zum einen
diplomatische Gründe aber zum anderen
das Transparenzregister ist so aufgebaut
dass man konkret rein also angeben muss
welche welcher gesetzgebungsakt
lobbiiert wird sozusagen wo man sich für
interessiert wo man dran arbeitet wie
viel Personen man da dran gesetzt hat
wie viel Geld man dafür einsetzt dass
Transparenzregister in der Europäischen
Union ist sehr viel schärfer als das im
Deutschen Bundestag aber da Länder zu
erfassen ist einfach von der Struktur
her relativ schwierig wenn allerdings
ein Land zum Beispiel
eine Art von Gesellschaft gegründet eine
unternehmensberatungs-dependence oder
sowas dann fallen sie dann natürlich
schon drunter weil sie dann eben genau
diesen Zweck verfolgen gut offenbar hat
das Land was jetzt gerade in der in dem
Mittelpunkt steht gar nicht nötig
irgendwelche extra Gesellschaften zu
gründen sondern macht das möglicherweise
ganz direkt hat das jetzt auch
Konsequenzen für dieses mutmaßliche
bestecherland offenbar Katha der
Innenausschuss ihres Parlaments hatte ja
gerade für erleichterte visa-regeln für
cataris gestimmt
ja diese Regelung ist ausgesetzt also
wir werden darüber neu beschließen wenn
wir mehr wissen für uns auch das Problem
ist dass wir eigentlich gar keine
offiziellen Informationen haben wir
wissen eigentlich auch nur was in der
Presse steht das heißt wir haben noch
nicht mal eine offizielle Bestätigung
wer dieses Land ist also wir wissen nur
es ist ein arabisches Land es spricht
viel für Katar aber sicher wissen wir
das noch nicht Katharina barley wie viel
zu Präsidentin des Europaparlaments
vielen Dank für das Gespräch
und das haben wir aus Termin Gründen vor
anderthalb Stunden aufgezeichnet so
Hanna du lieferst uns jetzt weitere
wichtige Nachrichten von heute die
eu-außenministerinnen und Minister haben
weitere Sanktionen gegen Iran verhängt
nachdem dort heute ein zweiter
regierungskritischer Demonstrant
hingerichtet wurde
bundesaußenministerin bärburg erklärte
es würden dabei diejenigen in den Blick
genommen die für Hinrichtungen und
Gewalt verantwortlich sein etwa die
revolutionsgarten die neuen Sanktionen
gegen Iran wurden auch wegen der
Unterstützung Russlands im Ukraine Krieg
beschlossen
die G7 Staaten haben einen
internationalen klimaclub gegründet der
allen Ländern mit ehrgeizigen
Klimazielen offen stehen soll das
erklärte Bundeskanzler Scholz nach einem
virtuellen Treffen der G7 Starts und
Regierungschefs konkret geht es um einen
klimafreundlichen Umbau der Industrie
und die Umsetzung der Pariser Klimaziele
ärmere Staaten die beitreten sollen
Unterstützung bekommen
Polens Präsident du da war heute zu
einem Treffen mit Bundespräsident
Steinmeier in Berlin dabei bedankte sich
duda für die Verlegung von Patriot
luftabwehrsystemen in sein Land und
sprach von einer sehr wichtigen Geste
eines Verbündeten und Nachbarn
Steinmeier betonte die entschiedene
Stärkung der NATO Ostflanke gehöre zur
erklärten Politik Deutschlands beide
Präsidenten unterstrichen auch die
gemeinsame Hilfe für die Ukraine in
ihrem Abwehrkampf gegen Russland
eine der zuletzt schwer getroffenen
Regionen in der Ukraine ist die
Hafenstadt Odessa die zusammengebrochene
Stromversorgung soll Stück für Stück
wieder aufgebaut werden noch sind
hunderttausende dort ohne Strom aber der
Hafen von Odessa kann seinen Betrieb
nach Angaben der Regierung wieder
aufnehmen
in Bayern und Sachsen-Anhalt ist die
maskenpflicht in Bus und Bahn bereits
Geschichte nun zieht auch
Schleswig-Holstein nach hier soll sie
zum Jahresende wegfallen das erklärte
heute Ministerpräsident Günther
stattdessen soll es im öffentlichen
Nahverkehr nur noch eine Empfehlung zum
Masken tragen geben unter anderem für
alle die zur Risikogruppe gehören oder
Erkältungssymptome haben
neue Erkenntnisse nach der großen Razzia
gegen sogenannte Reichsbürger haben
heute den Deutschen Bundestag
beschäftigt erschreckend sind die finden
viele Abgeordnete die
reichsbürgergruppierung hatte
offensichtlich deutlich mehr Mitwisser
als bisher bekannt mehr finanzielle
Mittel und mehr Gewaltbereitschaft und
auch die Diskussion um Extremisten im
Staatsdienst ist mit voller Macht zurück
Andreas Huppert berichtet
einen solchen Andrang den sie die
Mitglieder des Bundestags
Rechtsausschusses in der Regel nicht
gewohnt das Aufdecken der mutmaßlichen
Terrorzelle von reichsbürgern macht den
Ausschuss am Mittag zum Mittelpunkt wie
wahrscheinlich waren die Umsturzpläne
wie real der geplante bewaffnete
Überfall auf den Bundestag wir nehmen
das sehr ernst auch wenn wir vielleicht
nicht davon ausgehen müssen dass ein
wirklich Staatsstreich unmittelbar bevor
stand deshalb ist ja die Neigung bei
manchen Kommentatoren auch das ein
bisschen Lächerliche zu ziehen und dazu
besteht aus unserer Sicht eben kein
Anlass desto trotz sind die Ergebnisse
tatsächlich erschreckend erschreckend
was sowohl die Anzahl der involvierten
Personen eingeht was den
Professionalisierungsgrad angeht und
auch was die Finanzmittel angeht die
offenbar vorhanden waren
abhörsicher nur mit persönlicher
Einlasskontrolle Bundestag Untergeschoss
das Parlamentarische Kontrollgremium
tagt hier müssen regelmäßig die
deutschen geheimen Dienste Rechenschaft
über ihr Tun Ablegen von BKA
Verfassungsschutz und dem Militärischen
Abschirmdienst wollen die Abgeordneten
wissen wie die Gefährdungslage rund um
die Reichsbürger eingeschätzt wird dass
man nach den Anschlägen von Halle und
Hanau nach dem Mord an Walter Lübcke
nach den vielen rechtsextremistischen
Straftaten massiven Straftaten auch
mordaten hier von einer Gefährlichkeit
aus diesem Bereich ausgehen muss dass es
meiner Ansicht nach glasklar
die Frage der Wehrhaftigkeit wie sicher
ist die Demokratie was kann helfen sie
zu Stärken im Innenausschuss wollen Sie
darauf Antworten finden die SPD setzt
dabei auf eine Verschärfung des
Waffenrechts das ist immer wieder ein
Muster aus reichsbürgern aus
selbstverwaltern aus Gruppen die glauben
dass dieser Staat entweder nicht
existent ist und beseitigt werden muss
die aber auch ganz neu ein extremes
Gewaltpotenzial aufweisen die Zugang zu
Waffen haben also wir müssen auch das
Waffenrecht verschärfen die Linke will
eine effektivere und bessere Überprüfung
von Beamten von Polizisten und fordert
besonders die Elite Soldaten der
Bundeswehr unter die Lupe zu nehmen wir
müssen uns das Kommando Spezialkräfte
ansehen aus dieser Eliteeinheit gab es
so viele Vorfälle
in der Einheit selbst aber auch
Verbindung zu unterrichtsterrorverdacht
stehenden Gruppierungen wie Nordkreuz
oder zu einzelnen Soldaten bei den
Munition Waffen und Sprengstoff
aufgefunden wurde besonders im Fokus die
AFD verwurzelt dem rechtsnationalen
Milieu eine ihrer ehemaligen
Bundestagsabgeordneten wird zum engen
Kreis der Verdächtigen gezählt die
Partei wiegelt ab ein Staatsstreich mit
AFD Beteiligung sei das nicht gewesen es
scheint mir weniger umfänglich zu sein
als es vorab in der
pauschalen Bericht Erstattung
dargestellt wurden am Ende des heutigen
Tages bleibt eine AFD in Erklärungsnot
und die Erkenntnis die Umsturzpläne
waren mehr als die Viren Phantasien
rechter Spinner
Peru das reichste Land der Erde das ist
ein Spruch aus der Tourismuswerbung wo
Peru seine Goldschätze präsentiert seine
Naturwunder und die Küche die
mittlerweile auch international den Ruf
hat der ihr gebührt von Reichtum können
die allermeisten Menschen in Peru nur
träumen von einigermaßen stabilen
Verhältnissen auch dieses wunderschöne
Land hat einen korruptions-skandal nach
dem anderen und in den letzten sechs
Jahren sechs Präsidenten
der letzte sitzt jetzt im Gefängnis
Pedro castigo kam vom Land aus einfachen
Verhältnissen ein Linker der alles
anders und alles besser machen wollte
und seine Bürger nur noch mehr
enttäuschte eine Mehrheit will Neuwahlen
und glaubt gleichzeitig nicht mehr dass
sich dadurch etwas ändert im reichsten
Land der Erde regiert die Verzweiflung
christopherath
eine Schlägerei unter Parlamentariern in
Lima bringt es auf den Punkt Anhänger
und Gegner des abgesetzten Präsidenten
stehen einander verfeindet gegenüber und
draußen auf der Straße setzt sich das
fort auch in der letzten Nacht
durchbrechen die Demonstranten die
Sperren vor dem Parlament erst als die
Polizei Gewalt anwendet weichen sie
zurück seit Tagen demonstrieren tausende
in weiten Teilen Perus nachdem der
bisherige Präsident Petro Castillo vom
Parlament gestürzt worden war seine
Anhänger wollen das nicht hinnehmen
Freiheit für Pedro Castillo wir bitten
die Welt auf Peru zu schauen wir werden
von der Polizei und von verbrecherischen
neoliberalen Politikern missbraucht
um eine Misstrauensvotum wegen
Korruptionsvorwürfen zuvorzukommen hatte
castio versucht das Parlament aufzulösen
doch das blieb einfach sitzen und setzte
stattdessen ihn ab wegen moralischer
Unfähigkeit
Castillo ist in Untersuchungshaft und
seine bisherige Vizepräsidentin Dina
boulearte hat als erste Frau in Peru die
Macht übernommen in Anbetracht der
Proteste verspricht sie nun vorgezogene
Neuwahlen
mit dem Kongress eine Einigung zu
erzielen so dass wir die allgemeinen
Wahlen vorziehen können auf den April
ein Versuch die Lage zu beruhigen als
Linker Hoffnungsträger und
Quereinsteiger bei der ehemalige
Dorfschullehrer Castillo vor anderthalb
Jahren überraschend zum Präsidenten
gewählt worden doch seine Amtszeit ist
geprägt von Machtkämpfen mit dem
konservativen Parlament und von
Korruptionsaffären rund 70 Minister
verschleißt er in nur 18 Monaten
am Ende lehnen rund 2/3 der Peruaner die
Politik des Präsidenten ab dennoch ist
der Unmut groß über seine Absetzung
durch das Parlament denn bei all seinen
Fehlern war er einer von ihnen
er symbolisierte endlich den Zugang zu
politischer Vertretung für historisch
benachteiligte Gruppen und es ist sehr
wahrscheinlich dass selbst die
Demonstranten nicht mit allem
einverstanden sind was der Präsident
getan hat aber sie sind dagegen dass
Ihnen jetzt derjenige genommen wird von
dem sie sich grundsätzlich repräsentiert
fühlen
sehr repräsentiert die politische Krise
kommt für das Land zur Unzeit Pirol
leidet unter der schlimmsten Dürre seit
Jahrzehnten die Hälfte der Bevölkerung
ist von Ernährungsunsicherheit betroffen
und auch das facht jetzt die Wut vieler
an weil die Politik streitet anstatt zu
helfen
neue Regierung muss endlich dafür sorgen
dass sich das Volk in der Politik
wiederfinden kann
ein scheinbar einfaches Ziel an dem seit
Jahren die Regierungen scheitern zum
Leidwesen der Peruaner
ein Land in dem sich Parlament und
Präsident gegenseitig und mit einigem
Recht beschuldigen korrupt zu sein in
dem wenige immer reicher werden und alle
anderen die Folgen spüren
zurück nach Deutschland jetzt und
unseren Sorgen hier Hanna ja die
aktuelle massive Erkältungswelle sorgt
dafür dass viele Arbeitsplätze leer
bleiben und das hat mittlerweile Folgen
für Unternehmen und Behörden genauso wie
für Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher
Frank Bethmann welche sind das genau
naja ausgefallene Züge verschobene Ops
geschlossene Kitas ich denke fast jeder
von uns hat in den letzten Tagen so
etwas bereits erlebt der Krankenstand in
Deutschland ist so hoch wie seit drei
Jahren nicht mehr das Robert
Koch-Institut schätzt die Zahl der
Erkrankten auf 9 1/2 Millionen das sei
deutlich über dem Niveau der Vorjahre
dabei hat die Grippewelle ja erst
begonnen kann man denn schon absehen
welchen wirtschaftlichen Schaden das
haben könnte
na das ganze Ausmaß ist noch nicht
absehbar eben weil man ja noch nicht
sagen kann wie schlimm es noch wird aber
Gesundheitsökonomen rechnen die
Behandlungskosten mal außen vorgelassen
mit
Produktivitätsverlusten für Industrie
und Handel von über 3 Milliarden Euro
eben weil beispielsweise durchaus
gedüngte Fahrpläne manch einer verspätet
oder gar nicht zur Arbeit kommt die
Erkältungswelle bringt zudem auch viele
Kindergärten an den Rand des Kollaps die
Folge Eltern bringen ihre Kinder mit zur
Arbeit oder müssen sie zu Hause lassen
das alles bremst wobei zur Wahrheit auch
zählt der hohe Krankenstand ist es nicht
allein er trifft auf einen
Fachkräftemangel den es schon sehr viel
länger gibt und insbesondere dieser
Umstand macht die Situation jetzt so
brisant vielen Dank nach Frankfurt
die Mieten in Deutschland sind zuletzt
wieder stärker gestiegen laut einer
Analyse des Instituts der deutschen
Wirtschaft lag das Plus im vergangenen
Quartal im Schnitt bei 5,8% im Vergleich
zum Vorjahreszeitraum besonders
betroffen sein
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern mit einem
Aufschlag von 10,3 Prozent gefolgt von
Brandenburg und dem Saarland laut IB lag
der Anstieg vor allem an zwei Gründen
der hohen Inflation und den hohen
Bauzinsen die dazu führen dass viele
Menschen sich kein Eigentum mehr leisten
können
der deutsche Illustrator und
Kinderbuchautor Wolf Erlbruch ist tot er
starb im Alter von 74 Jahren in
Wuppertal zu seinen bekanntesten Werken
gehört die Illustration des Kinderbuchs
vom kleinen Maulwurf der wissen wollte
wer ihm auf den Kopf gemacht hat
Erlbruch veröffentlichte rund 30 Bücher
und wurde vielfach ausgezeichnet
darunter mehrfach mit dem Deutschen
Jugendliteraturpreis und 2017 mit dem
renommierten Astrid Lindgren
gedächtnispreis
und das war unser Montag im heute
journal vielen Dank für Ihr Interesse
unser heute journal Update mit Nazan
göktem
24.40 und uns gibt es morgen wieder wenn
Sie mögen Ihnen allen einen angenehmen
Abend
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter in den nächsten
Tagen stellt sich eine gefährliche
grenzwetterlage ein das bedeutet aus dem
Norden kommt kalte Luft oder aus dem
Südwesten relativ milde Luft und dort wo
sich diese Luftmassen treffen bildet
sich eine grenzwetterlage aus nach Süden
hin regnet es etwas weiter nach Norden
schneit es und dazwischen gibt es
gefrierenden Regen und der sorgt für
spiegelglatte Straßen schauen wir mal in
die kommende Nacht und da wird es nach
Südwesten einen auf klar sonst sind mehr
Wolken unterwegs Richtung Erzgebirge
verabschiedet sich der Schnee ganz im
Norden Richtung Schleswig-Holstein
bleibt der Schnee noch ja und die
Temperaturen sinken bis auf -16 Grad am
Alpenrand -17 Richtung Erzgebirge und -2
Richtung Ostsee ja und morgen
tagsverlauf viel Sonnenschein in der
Mitte und nach Südosten hin mehr Wolken
gibt es in den restlichen Landesteilen
immer noch Schneefall ganz im Norden und
im Südwesten da kommt schon der
Schneefall auf der zu dieser warmen Luft
gehört ja die Temperaturen die steigen
gerade mal auf -5 bis +2 Grad wobei in
der Osthälfte meist Dauerfrost herrscht
und den Mittwoch den schauen wir uns
nochmal genauer an also über der Mitte
dann viele Wolken mit Schneefall etwa
bis zum Main ganz im Süden der Regen und
dazwischen gefrierender Regen mit
glatten Straßen das den ganzen Tag über
Temperaturen -4 bis 0 Grad teils 5 Grad
im Südwesten und damit wünsche ich Ihnen
einen schönen Abend